it's past three o'clock
I haven't been able to sleep there's
this song that I want to do a rap to and
I've been just thinking lyrics all night
long so I decided I'm just gonna wake up
get up and do it three two one guys are
be something different something special
something fire some magic let's go I'll
wake up every day and I'm hustling I'm
dreaming gotta make sure that my life
has meaning turning my pain into purpose
trying to help others not feel some
worthless on the way up I can't be
stopped but then they get slapped by
another roadblock I doubt myself
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
here we go trillions of flights and
lambo supported meters they've got it
made and I also wanna be nice top like a
Paris and fix your mindset believe in
yourself it'll be your time yeah you've
got the right full of love just she's
here to be judge this ain't the [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
let's go sing upon cheese but leaves
believe believe believe believe believe
believe believe believe believe believe
believe believe believe believe believe
believe let's put it all together one
day fix let's go wake up every day and
I'm hustlin I'm dreamin gotta be true
that my life has meaning turnin my pain
into purpose trying to help others out
feel so worthless I'm gonna wake up I
can't be stopped but then it gets
slapped by another roadblock I tell
myself I feel so weak hollow one
another's make it seem so easy millions
of bugs and lamppost amitabh a better
day and I'm just a wannabe to stop that
comparison fix your mindset believe in
yourself it'll be your target your
direction if you lack of momentum you
fools about churches get a rejection is
it destruction your pointer departure
stop team that you didn't make the
correction believe